this week we've got infected tissues
pregnancy update and space adds space
ads mm-hmm for the first story
what kind of tissues like Kleenex that
sounds like a dope alternative been
affected - yeah I love that bad dude
yeah so there are these pre infected $80
tissues that claim that it will help you
prepare for the flu season instead of
taking back seen Matt [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I only get sick when I get flu
vaccinations yes actually
Sam that's I don't do it anymore like
the last two years I've been taking on
it and I haven't got sick once and I
didn't do any flu vaccinations whatever
when I was in the military you have to
get the flu vaccination it's required by
the government every single time I got
sick for six years straight I mean to
when I worked at the hospital and you
get sick from it I would get sick mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] I haven't gotten a flu in
a minute because you don't get the
vaccination see you I hate [ __ ]
coughing dude I hate a stuffy nose but
it when it's only one taking it too much
I I rather had the flu than the cold cuz
the flu will go away right but the
coffin the stuffy nose stays for a
[ __ ] minute I had coffee so much I
don't look a [ __ ] dumbass this is
what I do I go you fart when you call I
don't know why I appreciate the cop car
oh I do sometimes but this is all I do
it's not a car I hate it so much I'll
just do this mmm
because I don't want a cop so I'm just
saying it sometimes you're copying so
much or hurts inside it makes you
believe you could taste the blood
sometimes your bronchitis bro that's
bronchitis no it's cuz I'm copying so
much
that's bronchitis oh really yeah maybe I
bronchitis a couple times in my life and
I just dealt with this for sure for
coughing that much maybe it's just got a
violin s confer too huh the last time I
was coughing coughing - there was Glenn
coming up like I was caught yeah one
which is a good thing though you got to
get it out of there cuz I don't work
Google bit and it was either between
bronchitis or the other one or cancer no
that's what happens when you googled
yeah flu likes or you broke your leg
well what's the difference between the
Bronk Bronk ëitís in the cops owned
ammonia bronchitis is just an
inflammation of your airway and it
usually comes from coughing you're doing
some other cooped-up squack that makes
home I've had bronchitis quite a few
times ago yeah your severe bronchitis
for like a long long time then you have
to take antibiotic yeah Hospital that's
should only lasted like five six days
dude only oh that a long time that's a
while that's normal that's normal
bronchitis that's normal if you're doing
like two weeks you gotta go to the doc I
just take those little cough drops and
then I take this is this nasty red cough
cough drop that tastes like [ __ ] holy
stuff yeah that [ __ ] because it has that
zinc in there and it destroys your taste
buds for like a week I like all the
girls suits me though I do this I cam
now cuz it's all like nasal it's the
same kind of like cold remedy deal but
this one does not have zinc and I swear
by it now it works long to feel sick you
spray in your nose you let everything
drain back and it basically makes that
environment totally inhospitable to
anything that wants to move in are we
gonna see your face on the packaging
hashtag add hashtag sponsored high as I
can follow me i gargle with you love you
even more
cuz I've done me nasal spray right it's
a nasal it's orange and white the bottom
yes yes your nasal sprays before but
then it'll be perfect in the moment that
I use then ever it wears off that's a
three
I don't do none of that [ __ ] you know
when you get a stuffy nose and then you
have a stuffy nose on one side and when
you go to sleep it moves to the other
side yeah what is that it is like that I
just [ __ ] try to like breathe netipot
no I mean I take care of myself that
well when I'm sick I just try to like
wait it out that's not good
well anyway so this company here I don't
do it I will do it yeah it's called
vivre I don't take no pills like very
ver wait they're straight up tissues
yeah so they're tissue and it's crawled
up already [ __ ] you are they just you
it's not used by other people so what
these lucky just dig in a trash can and
get the same [ __ ] I know so they're
saying that the website states that it's
tissue carries a human sneeze but then
it explains that it's specifically
engineered to contain an absorbed
colloid buildup salts antiseptic enzymes
immunoglobin and glycoproteins such as
lactoferrin and mucus I hate lactoferrin
produced by goblet cells in the mucous
membranes didn't make it upwards no hado
great I know I'm good on this [ __ ]
sounds like some Gwyneth Paltrow [ __ ] do
you guys know if the flu is like the
cold where it's not the same thing every
time
yeah how do they know that this year's
flu they could prepare for that's what a
lot of people have the conspiracy
theories of those flu shots that they
give you they're actually giving you the
new flu to spread that's a conspiracy
theory well I haven't had a flu shot in
like [ __ ] 15 years all right and I've
gotten the flu every time we get the
[ __ ] flu well you've got it from one
of the people that got a flu shot
well I always get it like it's so weird
because I know what I'm gonna get it
like for example this year I got the flu
because I trained with people who said
they got over the flu and I was a little
weird the most contagious exactly and
then [ __ ] boom two days later the flu
I'm like you son of a [ __ ] you gave it
to me let's just contagious ass bug man
especially if you make out with your
training partners I know she's suck yeah
the [ __ ] idiom brush her teeth or
anything
oh okay next story why is it a secret
I know it's not his fight coach it's his
kissing coach yeah that's right that's
my kissing coach you're getting better
you know what I said was the crush yeah
it's the tongue jujitsu Oh
so for our next story do you guys
remember we recently talked about that
woman who was in a vegetative state and
got oh yeah yeah yeah yeah in Arizona
yeah all right so we found out they
found out who the baby daddy was yes the
ethnicity who the baby daddy I can't be
here Filipino man Filipino female no mix
it up so he's actually Haitian oh he
came over when he was young when he was
like seven years old at that Caribbean
yeah Oh Haiti yeah so his name is Nathan
stop making the Haitian yeah best type
he's 36 years old he was a nurse he was
a nurse there he looks like they take
the photo when he was like this what a
piece of [ __ ] is he winking like I did
it he was like he legit looks like
Jordan Peele if his career didn't go
right oh my god that's so true
I wanna I want to hate this guy a lot
but because you've said that this is
making it difficult now I just feel bad
for Jordan B I have a lot of hate for
the both of us so no yeah it's like a
character he's playing like Jordan Peele
playing his characters nice yes so they
found the DNA matched the baby Oh
her family's lawyer has clarified her
state so originally it was reported that
she was in a vegetative state right yeah
it says quote the victim's parents would
like to make a make clear that their
daughter is not in a coma
she has significant intellectual
disabilities as a result of seizures
very early in her childhood she does not
speak but has some ability to move her
limbs head and neck oh no no she
does respond to sound and is able to
make facial so she might have been
conscious she was conscious hi how many
times how many times are there other
victims because there there are others
you know it is a one-time thing
oh for sure tonight there are other
women in the same area where she was
held that he took care of oh my god or
other people remember Kill Bill yeah
it's the I like to [ __ ] so now he's been
arrested and then every what's why I
love animals so much animals rape
animals are pretty V dolphins not pretty
rare yeah
ducks damnit then I love no one craw
fish I no crawfish crawfish big fish
rape they rape what yeah well that's why
we eat the ducks rape dachshund grape
Ducks are awful because they're like Oh
animals rape because the lady bits and
the male bits are just each other turned
inside out but they're a corkscrew shape
the corkscrew shape is opposite so it
doesn't fit in perfectly it fits in
opposite so the Ducks corkscrew shape
literally has to like cut through the
female in the opposite way they would
expect like they're like me worse it's
painful and worse it's barbed so yeah
there's wasps later species rape like
they'll see a nice fat juicy caterpillar
just fly outta Noah and his stick the
steamer into the caterpillar and inject
it full of its eggs now the eggs live
off the caterpillar nature is [ __ ]
crazy
there's no romance in nature except
maybe for a monk now monkeys rape
monkeys are pretty monkeys are the wild
ones yeah swans mate for life
alright that's it that's a give us hold
okay yeah penguins watch that but they
also fight to the death
penguins yeah each other's baby they
steal each other's don't tell me that
y'all thought they'd throw down with
each other and then they fight to the
death [ __ ] out of here it's that it's a
daddy daycare
daddies take care cuz if I if I was a
penguin and somebody was like well I'm
just gonna incubate your egg I'm like
stupid go ahead and [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] other Penguins in the meantime
Wow Wow well what's the sound of the
penguin penguin penguin
I don't know they're not Pokemon works
dude I think that's how it works they
should name animals based off the sounds
so you could just memorize all the
animals easier Oh [ __ ] Pokemon has
gotten so [ __ ] lazy it's hilarious
like the names of the yeah they're like
this is Crooklyn bottle hmong so sad now
they're running out of ideas garbodor is
a garbage garbage door yeah I definitely
brought in a whole list there this is
what a c'mon what a cats could literally
be one exact like a lot of cash and it
revolves in a fat stacks yeah what are
they doing to the Haitian dude yeah yeah
yeah and he immediately got fired
he needs to get is why her parents are
dead you still doing his job
there are doctors are they suing the
business - or the the hospital yeah I
know
did you just say there's two doctors
that been [ __ ] - no no so there are
two doctors that no longer work there
after this whole thing happened cuz
they're disgusted one of them was
suspended the other one like Oh for
negligence yeah because no one and like
all these health care professionals
none of them realized that she was
pregnant like oh not until she was
giving birth like that oh is it the
policy in the hospital for somebody to
be with somebody like it's like if I
don't know if I had some like now they
have that policy where there's no male
staff that can be alone but I thought
that's how hospitals are supposed to be
though well not necessarily because I
mean there's male nurses that have to
bathe their patients and like did do a
lot of [ __ ] like they have to change
them they have to move like you know
like help them poop and all that stuff
so and not everyone can work in pairs
but this place now they made it
mandatory where they have to have a
female I agree
I know but at least I mean the good
thing out of all this is that the baby
isn't a loving family that's good put a
little Haitian little baby God
but it's gonna look like that [ __ ]
disgusting man
well let's hope that they don't have a
little baby lazy eye they also report
that this dude has kids I don't know how
many probably a million all over the
place no baby I delays yeah they
wouldn't have to do the DNA test I know
who's the daddy I don't feel like that's
all we didn't do a DNA they just thought
a little baby like this and they're like
okay we know that is you know it is his
little hair came out a little [ __ ]
braids on the side of [ __ ] they also
report that he was um he was a gospel
rapper it's so [ __ ] funny
just reading off his MySpace page moving
on to the last story here there's this
Russian startup that plans to have these
massive space billboards in the sky that
we can see from Earth ya know that's
some way no just make a dream the night
sky that's some Futurama [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah exactly so this you startup is
called start start rocket and I want C
as in this guy man yeah how can they
even control that yeah
well that's actually what they are
trying to sort of stake out right yeah
because there are no international laws
against this so right now they're kind
of like ooh booming industry let me show
you guys this video just kiddin news and
everybody see it
focus just keepin news man I would love
that [ __ ] alright I'm gonna play this
video I don't know what's going on
that's just so far you know telescope to
see that [ __ ] Oh
is that even real as common as a cheese
it's like a pixel and they have these
sales they expand and then reflect light
from the Sun Oh light sales that's like
the next level of us getting energy not
on earth that's equivalent they're gonna
use a Sun to propel it oh [ __ ]
first of all that is [ __ ] amazing you
want to see it in the or or borealis you
[ __ ] yeah is that not an invasion of
like a certain countries like airspace
like if it's directly about the America
couldn't it be like all right this is
our airspace I will build a company that
shoots rockets into space to destroy
these ads good idea
I think people that'll be cool Dave lift
the ads up and then all [ __ ] shoot
try to [ __ ] take the beautiful
picture with my girlfriend and a [ __ ]
lake and in the sky it says pornhub
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they're saying that
these cubes they will cause light
pollution which can affect human mental
health as well as behavior of animals of
animals for sure
it would make me feel like I've never
left a building yeah yeah it's never
nighttime it would true me to show my
[ __ ] ass dude it's daytime all day
how much you wanna bet somehow a tiger
is still gonna be able to climb onto
that being a spray paint on that thing
all that'd be dope just watch again they
told me I couldn't do it on the freeway
signs I see like the craziest [ __ ] I'm
like this fool is a [ __ ] expert rock
climber or something cuz Tigers are
everywhere dude that'd be tight he has
his little [ __ ] cholo chalk pouch
right here he's all portering up there
yeah that'd be [ __ ] me gets up there
and sees the pixels are for cholo chalk
pouch and it's just like no no I could
choose that's [ __ ] tight you know some
billionaire trolls are gonna like buy
ads saying like dick or suck [ __ ] or
some [ __ ] Elon Musk
yeah it's like everyone has to see it
like [ __ ] I know they're also saying
that I could interfere with astronomical
observations [ __ ] pornhub example
exactly you're trying to look at a
once-in-a-lifetime eclipse and it just
is tits and ass I'll be so pissed dude I
like being away from the computer like I
don't have that like we have enough ads
yeah yeah all over I don't want more
this is some [ __ ] black nerd [ __ ]
dude I don't like it
yeah so one of the members of start
rocket like the team sounds like a
[ __ ] dildo
stupid stupid name they're selling gold
uh yeah so they said quote if you ask
about advertising and entertainment in
general haters gonna hate
we're developing a new medium at the
advent of Elon Musk advent of television
no one loved ads at all
I still don't love ads yeah nobody that
hasn't changed it's also like ads are
supposed to pay for things usually like
you know I think billboards generally go
back to the highway somehow right and
like it's on TV because you're watching
TV not like finally someone could pay
for the damn sky yeah whoo how we're
gonna maintain the sky yes I hate that
so much maybe you could like because
there's so much pollution space
pollution we like dead satellites and
like pieces of space shuttles maybe it
could go towards it cleaning it up maybe
but I'm not seeing any dead satellites
yeah would be seeing chalk pouch would
be seeing pornhub.com I think I'm gonna
develop a missile company that's a great
idea
Oh what if we just got a rush and kill
these [ __ ] before they arrive
oh yeah the Russians and we're gonna
[ __ ] just kill them like nothing but
good things like the craziest people to
[ __ ] with I didn't think it through
they're also investing in hey Ivan oh
thank God I'm a [ __ ] bears mouth how
about that let's try the roads in there
yeah like we're talking about this now
let's see you know in a couple years
from now or maybe in a decade or two
this is the norm no man I hope not the
only thing I want to advance is [ __ ]
virtual reality I want to say to advance
so [ __ ] well dude I love it
let's say if I just want to go into
Hawaii real quick just for like 10
minutes put on my [ __ ] I think we're
close I'd rather have that idea where
anywhere in the world you could travel
by rocket and get anywhere in the world
in an hour nah [ __ ] that that's too
expensive I'm talking about nowhere it's
like as cheap as an airline impossible
rocket fuel is [ __ ] ridiculous that's
what they've said it'll be so why I know
that is because I had this genius idea
to take all the trash in the world and
[ __ ] shoot it out into the Sun and
it's impossible because that amount of
fossil fuel to get that it's ridiculous
just billions of dollars and we can't
use that type of fossil fuel so it
doesn't make any sense if you do the
virtual reality thing how are you gonna
get sunburned then huh no I'm just
saying it for a quick fix like it's not
to replace it but it's like dude I just
need to go to Hawaii I'm gonna take some
fish I'm gonna put it on my nose it's
like the avatar 13 times oh yeah I've
already had some VR experiences where it
was like three or four hours at a time
and I really felt like I was like I'm in
this man yeah I went to the Star Wars
smell it and did you feel it on the skin
I didn't smell it feel it but I like
there's I mean they're they're games now
where like if you are crouching down and
leaning down like that's what you're
doing in the game so yeah for some like
robots coming around the corner and I
like found a knife in the game and I was
like literally waiting in the corner and
like if you could like teleport yourself
so I like teleported then crouched down
and waited for this thing to pop up and
then like stabbed it in the neck and I
was just like that was the most real
thing I've ever felt and I don't feel
good about this fake robot dying in
front of me like this er experience
where you can feel what it feels like to
be a tree which sounds funny but oh I
thought they pretty much like they have
these earphones on you headphones rubber
and then the viewer thing and then
there's like fans so you could it
consume you late the wind and then in a
bar shading on you see it grow right and
then I get this little point where
there's like this forest fire and then
you feel the heat because they have
heaters oh my god and then the floor is
like trembling - it's like you have this
whole experience and your arms are the
branches so just going
oh my god feel some squirrels [ __ ] on
your head and [ __ ] they make a hole in
you so that they can mess oh the [ __ ]
[ __ ] woodpecker oh damn we just
[ __ ] up that hole pleasant experience
here trying to shake over again as a
seedling after the forest fire it wasn't
really meant to be a pleasant thing it
was meant to like it was commenting on
like the whole environment thing and
like I can't empathize with the [ __ ]
tree though you can't tell I like I love
trees and you know when those huge
redwoods they fall down I understand but
I'm not gonna go through the spirits to
feel what a tree goes through because
they don't give a [ __ ] either so it's
like you know I mean yeah they
communicate through the roof
what if trees are like I want to go do
this experience of being a human and
they go let me be a tree again [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah my heart broke into [ __ ] oh I
can't do this pain yeah that's right
poetry is [ __ ] what is this back in the
force like y'all hear that yeah
[Music]
[Music]